so we've come inside to the hall here
just to show you some of the areas where
people are sleeping some people still
actually asleep now and these are people
who've lost their homes really getting
what they can on makeshift mattresses
here but there is a big problem because
lots of people who've lost their homes
don't want to come in here and you can
see why you can see some of the bricks
here have fallen onto the floor and
people are concerned that they've
already survived two earthquakes and
they're really worried that if there was
another one that this whole building
could come down so some people just
aren't risking it and they're determined
to sleep elsewhere in their cars outside
or in tents